and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists shell bissell shell bizzle
in the house
that's me Shelby is here today today
we're going to talk about certain things
that we stop buying is minimalist we're
gonna talk about why we stopped buying
them we're talking about tips for
purchasing new things Shelby I got your
one of your videos from Jessica the guy
who runs our social media she's like you
got to have this girl on the podcast and
so she does that sometimes and they're
like I'm like no not not this one god no
and then I saw this it was a video you
did about things you stopped buying I'm
like yeah yeah she's right and because
it's something that we often talk about
so so you do videos on YouTube about
eco-friendly living about sustainability
and you did this video about the things
that you stopped buying so we're gonna
answer some folks questions today before
we get into that he talked to me just
about maybe three things that you've
stopped buying since you've started
living more sustainably more minimally
yeah definitely well I call it eco
minimalism right so there are all
different reasons you could be a
minimalist but mine is because it
reduces the demand for products and also
obviously reduces your carbon footprint
your water footprint all the above so
tons of things I've stopped buying I
have several thoughts about it but you
know anything from like paper towels to
plastic water bottles to new clothes I
haven't bought new clothes in years all
kinds of stuff those are definitely that
was like the hardest thing for you stop
buying do you have one of those I mean
yeah just everything that it takes a
while to shift right because we're doing
life one certain way because it's
convenient yeah so changing up any of
those things makes your life a lot less
convenient overall so that's a really
unfair question because people always
ask me and they're like so what's the
hardest thing you had to you know get
rid of and it's like there's so many
things but yeah it's kind of a growing
and evolution and each step is it can be
a little bit difficult for sure Ryan
whatever what are some things that you
stopped buying before we jump into our
first question here so man I wrote down
six things here cuz we had talked about
this I stopped buying Oreos
so lovell aureus
like I was a sucker I'd go into the
grocery store and like they always got
me with like special Oreo Edition like
20 flavors yeah exactly so I have not
bought any more Oreos but I've replaced
it with 100% chocolate and I think when
we you know talk about what we stopped
buying some of these things not every
single one of them but some of these
things we do have to replace it with
some better habits because if we don't
do that then you know at least for me
like I just end up buying all the crap
that if I if I haven't you know replace
it with something something else replace
it with another bad habit like well I
stopped by an Oreo so I started buying
hostess cut loose weight a minute a
second it wasn't the ideal trade-off
there so give me give me two more things
so man all right I got I'm just gonna
read these out for a book dress shoes
suits so I stop stop stop stop there
stop we're gonna save the other ones for
patreon later okay
so dress shoes dress shoes and suits
yeah so dress shoes haven't really
replaced those with anything because I
don't have any suits anymore but I mean
now I just have a uniform that like I
will wear I mean pretty much this I got
a pair of jeans that all wear for
weddings or funerals funny how my my
outfits the same for a wedding or a
funeral pretty much the same thing I
have a list of a lot of things with my
top three on this list I stopped buying
coupons items so like items that are on
I stopped I stopped when we go to CVS
there's a CVS right by my house and the
other day I walked out of the I bought I
literally bought a pack of gum yeah and
they gave you like a manuscript oh the
receipt I was dragging on the floor yeah
literally like on the ground before I
could drag it out to the trash gasps
also back is like look at much paper
that I think we would save we would we
would solve the environmental crisis if
we could just get CVS to stop printing
receipts yeah it was obscene I didn't I
never look at it but they every time
they print out who was that who wrote
the road not McCarthy I'm sorry I'm on
the road yeah Jack Kerouac
thank you podcast shot and apparently he
originally wrote
on the road with on what is that yeah
what is it butcher paper yeah so it was
like this giant receipt essentially yeah
and that's when I feel like every time I
got to CVS I don't use coupons anymore
there's a reason why though I found that
coupons were forced to me like I
would've looked at that CVS receipt I
would have started just oh yeah look
this I save a dollar on something I
don't need I might as well buy it now
because buyers in seven days sometimes
though like what those receipts like
it'll be like hey here's five CVS
dollars and I know I'm gonna go and buy
shampoo at some point I mean so we're
like Mariah now we got a little envelope
but it is difficult to like stave off
that impulse words like oh it's I get
five dollars off of this you know bag of
chips or this bar of chocolate maybe
I'll try it out because it's on sale
like yeah it certainly can lead you down
- yeah and loss of buying past I know
where my boundary is and it will force
me to be more impulsive than that
second thing discounted items so that's
another thing that really gets me when
it's on sale it's 50% off I'd be dumb
not to buy it
what's 100% off if I don't buy it yeah
and so I don't know it doesn't it
doesn't mean that I won't take advantage
by a new pair of shoes only happened to
be on sale you're not gonna be like all
wait till they go off of sale I'm not
burning money I just no longer make that
the primary decision-maker for yeah if
the sale price triggers the impulse to
buy like that's where you've got to stop
yourself and be like wait a minute
would I buy this thing if it wasn't on
sale yeah and last but not least I have
stopped buying into being busy yeah I
paid a lot for it unfortunately and and
that was the problem like I was in fact
I was talking to the gals at and we work
yo so how's your day going real busy I'm
like I'm really sorry to hear that
instead sometimes my days are full like
today is a full day but I try to stave
off being busy for the sake of being
busy allowing other people to sort of
dictate the the direction of my to-do
list I got a list of a bunch more things
we'll cover those in a bit but our first
question today is from Nathan in College
Station Texas school
that's audit he's from Canada I I wrote
down um on my notes he's the keys the
Canadian Texan previous podcast you both
have talked about getting rid of certain
things but enjoying enjoying them when
they're owned by others for example of
Christmas decorations you might not have
Christmas decorations but you might go
around and enjoy others is that a that a
feasible is that a feasible thing if you
know in some ideal future everybody is
acting as they as a minimalist is this
like a sustainable way to act as a
minimalist because you know if everybody
is getting rid of those kinds of things
then you know then what will there be
free for you to enjoy may that thick
Texas accent yeah man so what if
hypothetical questions didn't exist
why does everyone's mind go to the
extreme versions of everything so
quickly I think it's like it's human
nature I mean we've gotta like test our
boundaries right yeah and you know
that's very easy to do with these mental
exercises I think it's a good question I
mean if everyone stopped purchasing
things let's just go to that I mean cuz
that's just the next step to what he's
talking about then the economy would
crash right it's what if everyone did
something something is always a bad
question unless that is breathed it's
the only thing that we can all agree on
is breathe you can go on water no no no
not drinking water viv plenty of plenty
of videos on YouTube I'll find one put
in the shows where people talk about
water is dehydrating we can't even agree
on water being hydrating okay and so
what if everyone stopped drinking water
and then I don't know we would all and
have a water crisis we'd have a
different crisis so Shelby I assume you
get questions about this stuff because
you live sustainably you're yourself and
it inspires other people to live
sustainably through your videos on
YouTube which by the way we'll put a
link to several of your videos including
the one I mentioned at the top of the
show and on our show notes but you have
you have people who ask well what if
everyone stopped blank yeah
how do you talk about that I I mean I
feel the same way that you guys just
mentioned that it people go to the
extreme so quickly so I do get that
question all the time
how would you buy second-hand if
everybody started buying secondhand and
then there was no new clothes to buy
second-hand my answer to that is then we
would switch over to a sustainable
economy where people are producing
clothing sustainably I feel like it's a
similar situation with Christmas
decorations I also don't own any but
like I told you it's because of the eco
minimalist situation I mean I but if we
stop making Christmas decorations and
they wouldn't be there I feel like my
life wouldn't be that heavily impacted
yeah I mean well to me it's it's like if
we started doing if everyone started
taking the approach that that nathan
said here like we would have more of a
sharing community mm-hmm and like we
have more access to stuff yeah having to
own everything right exactly but like
you know Josh and I we still buy stuff
like you still buy stuff it's just we're
more deliberate with those purchasing
dollars and you know it's not just our
dollars that we're deliberate with I
mean it's all of our resources so with
Nathan's question it's like yes go ahead
and have a substitute for things that
you want to buy if there's something
that is a better option more sustainable
or for whatever reason yes do that until
it's not a good decision yeah it's
sustainable until it no longer is
exactly and when I think about when I
think about the things that I buy right
now it's different from the things I
bought a decade ago and it'll be a
different a decade from now we're going
to talk about some of those things
minimalism isn't about not buying
anymore it's about being more deliberate
with well-wrought what Ryan said is the
resources we have part of that's money
and that certainly ties into the economy
and I'm gonna talk about how you can
stimulate the economy like a minimalist
in a moment but it also has to do with
your time your attention your energy and
and no I don't think everyone is going
to become a minimalist I don't think you
could force everyone we can't force
everyone to do anything
at this point and so you're not gonna
force anyone to do it by the way I don't
want to force people to become
minimalist what that's a really bad plan
I want to inspire people to live more
deliberately whether or not you call
that sustainability or eco-friendly or
you call that minimalism or simplicity
or intentionality I don't care what you
call it what ism you put on it what I'm
more concerned about is maybe I can
inspire a few people to live more
deliberately to live a more meaningful
life with less but not force them into
that situation and maybe for some people
living with Christmas decorations it is
worth having right because we all have
different things that you would think is
important and I wouldn't my sister is
obsessed with Christmas and I'm never
gonna try to take that away from her so
I think we would never see the
extinction of Christmas decoration
because there are some people out there
who do value that enough for that to be
something that they continue yeah one of
my ex-girlfriends her mom had I've
counted him one time I was like over 300
Santa's that were in her house like it
was just statues some of them were no no
it was it was interesting though because
I started to notice this at it was when
I counted him it was like the first year
that we had started the minimalists
calmly she has all he's saying is but
the thing is is like her house is
beautiful during Christmas time like she
absolutely like does a good job of
displaying these in a way that it really
makes you feel you know that warm fuzzy
holiday feeling and you're right like I
would never want to take that away from
anyone I think that's the key the key
takeaway here is we can appreciate
things whether it's a Picasso painting
yeah I don't think I'll ever have enough
money to own a Picasso painting by the
way if I did I can I don't think I would
buy one right there's something else I
could do with that money however it does
mean I can't appreciate good al Ahmed
they have a whole Picasso display and I
can appreciate that without needing to
hoard the thing to own the thing to have
the thing for my self in fact it's
actually better that it's in a museum
because I'm not the only one who can
appreciate that now and the same is true
with the Santa's imagine if your former
girlfriend's mother just like hoarded
them in a special room just for herself
it wouldn't have had the same impact to
the other people they were like wow this
is really cool
I can appreciate this and and I think
that's that's that's what we where we
need to start where it comes to not it's
not about not owning anything right it's
about having access to the things we
don't want to own that's really nice
whether it's your shared ride services
or a community pool or okay you can go
to when I was a kid in the 80s in Dayton
Ohio we went to a basketball court I
didn't own a basketball court because
again that's something else I'll
probably never be able to afford having
my own backyard basketball court but who
cares as long as I have access to one
that's that's what's important yeah I
think if we ask ourselves with any items
that you know insert whatever there be
says Christmas decorations like asking
ourselves like is our life better or is
it worse without it and if it's worse if
you're depriving yourself like that is
not what any of us really are trying to
propagate here it's not about
deprivation it's not about making
yourself miserable it's about doing
things deliberately so we can stave off
those impulses that we all have I mean
one thing we can all agree on is like we
live in a very and consumeristic
impulsive buying society that it's not
sustainable and I mean what's the
statistic if everyone consumed like in
an American it would take ya something
crazy like a ders to sis yeah it's it's
uh it's just not sustainable well you
know what Nathan I'm missing you a copy
of our book essential it's an essay
collection with twelve different
chapters about twelve different areas of
intentional living but one of those
chapters about finances and there's an
essay in there called stimulate the
economy like a minimalist I'm gonna read
an excerpt from that really quick for
you but if you like our podcast you like
the audiobook version of that book it's
our longest audio book I think it's over
6 hours or if you want the book book or
the e-book podcast Jean we'll be happy
to send you those as well if everyone
immediately stops spending their money
our economy would crash this goes
without saying consequently one of the
biggest supposed arguments many people
have against minimalism is that if
everyone became a minimalist then we'd
all be doomed the financial system as it
stands today would collapse and no
longer will we have the wealth necessary
to purchase cheap plastic crap from
Walmart
there are several problems with this
point of view some obvious some a bit
more abstruse first no informed person
would argue that we should stop spending
money or that we must stop consuming
consumption is not the problem
consumerism is the problem consumerism
is compulsory vapid pernicious impulsive
unfocused and misguided worst of all it
is seductive consumerism shiny facade
promises more than it can possibly
deliver because love happiness
contentment and satisfaction are all
internal feelings that cannot be
commodified and the truth is that once
our basic needs are met the acquisition
of trinkets does little for our lifelong
well-being using consumerism to
stimulate the economy is like fixing a
cracked mirror with a hammer it only
worsens the problem yes trade is an
important part of any society
circumventing consumerism however
doesn't imply that minimalist sidestep
commerce rather minimalism is predicated
on intentionality which means we spend
our money more deliberately minimalist
invests in experiences over possessions
travel indie concerts vacations
community theater etc we can all spend
money without acquiring new material
things I guess an important point here
like you're still stimulating the
economy you're just doing so differently
right you're still spending money as
someone who's interested in
sustainability you're not saying well
I'm never gonna use money again and
you're not allergic to money either last
time I checked minimis buy new
possessions carefully we do so to do so
we must ask better questions like will
this thing add value to my life in a
moment we'll talk about six questions we
ask before purchasing that's one of them
middlemost support local businesses
local indie shops tend to be less
motivated by profit sure they need to
make money to keep the lights on and
there's nothing wrong with that but
earning a buck usually isn't the primary
concern of a local bookstore
restaurateur or bike shop they are in
business because they are passionate
about their product or service and they
want to share that passion with their
patrons passion baguettes greater
quality and better service which makes
the money they earn
deserved ultimately mentalists aren't
ultimately memos aren't concerned or
interested in stimulating the economy
stimulation is ephemeral we rather
improve our economies long-term health
by making better individual decisions
about consumption getting involved in
our community and support or supporting
local businesses who care if more people
do this will build a stronger economy
one that's predicated on personal
responsibility and community interaction
not a false sense of urgency and the
mindless stockpiling of junk we never
needed in the first place Ryan what time
is it you know it Simon is it it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we're at the minimus on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram
we have Shelby here she's at shell Basel
which we'll put a link to that the show
notes
you can't spell there's several E's at
the end there and they'll put a link to
all of her social media in the show
notes as well what's our first question
Ryan my first question is from Nicole
from patreon she says Amazon makes it
too easy to be impulsive very very true
but it's so convenient since I don't
like shopping in person how can I cut
back she'll bizzle well it's really
interesting a lot of people look at
Amazon as a way to like get things
really fast and impulsively but for me
shopping online stops me from looking
through all the aisles at a store I
don't know if you guys have a similar
like viewpoint of it but I don't have to
walk through all the aisles at the store
and see all the stuff that I don't need
so for me Amazon I still use Amazon
don't tell anybody but for me yeah I
don't go browse Amazon if I need
something I do this thing where I have
to put it on a list and wait 30 days so
you got boundaries set up right yeah I
mean that's that's really what that's
that's what I would tell Nicole here I
mean my short answer is No Boundaries
equals no impulse control yeah so when
you set boundaries up like that you give
yourself a 30-day waiting period or you
go to Amazon and you just or the one
thing that you went there for it is
difficult though like you know sometimes
I got the little recommended stuff but
you know I never thought about that
point about you know browsing the aisles
you're right like that's that is that's
actually kind of a plus with with online
shopping yeah well just the way I grew
up because my mom I used to be the same
but
as a Shopaholic so we would just like
that was entertainment for us going to
the stores and walking through the
aisles and just finding things so I that
is a huge part of like being a minimus
for me is not going to the mall not
going to Target so yeah it makes me
think of like when I used to buy
Christmas gifts I would just you know I
had no idea what I was gonna get friends
or family so I just go to the mall right
and like look for inspiration like oh
maybe maybe I'll find some inspiration
walking around but like buying gifts
that way to me is like one of the most
unintentional ways it's there's not a
lot of thought in that it's just
shopping like that in general right
searching for consumeristic inspiration
is not something I'm inspired by you
could tweet that podcast shot by the way
we put all these minimal Maxim's and the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like Shonda squeezes out the things that
sound profound and puts them in the show
notes for us my short answer today is
today's convenience is often tomorrow's
headache and that's the one thing if we
don't have the boundary set up the 30
day boundary or what Ryan and I have
something called a 30-30 rule if
something calls for more than thirty
dollars wait 30 hours so basically a day
and to buy this thing because on Amazon
they've removed all the friction to the
point where you might slip into
consumerism because there's no friction
at all it's like this iced skid that
you're just slide you don't realize it
like oh no what
well actually you do realize it when
when when the boxes show up at the house
what did I do in my apartment building
actually they check in the box in front
that's every time that like I order
something I get an email notification
about it and there was one day I had a
bunch of like supplements coming for the
the stuff had been going through with my
stomach and I didn't realize why they
were coming all these I didn't know they
were coming different boxes so one day I
had like five different boxes show up
and I'm like I'm such a fraud I'm not a
real minimalist why do I have all the
and then I realize like oh the this was
something I intentionally purchased and
they just showed up in five boxes of
tapes and open yeah right but we do need
we do need those boundaries because as
Ryan said without those boundaries the
impulses will run wild yeah I'm
all right our next question is from ow
how do I stop myself from buying food I
don't need so he's asking how he stops
buying Oreos replaced it with better
things it was what's interesting though
is when you're giving up a food habit
that first week or two or even month it
is you go through this withdrawal of
like whether it's fried food or sugar so
there's a lot of discomfort that you're
going to have to accept that you're
gonna go through but like now dude
alright so here's here's like confession
time
so yesterday I was walking home and I
was like man I've not been to Roscoe's
chicken yet like the everyone talks
about Roscoe's chicken in LA and I'm
like I keep talking about how you know
I've been here for almost two years and
I keep talking about I'm gonna try it I
was starving it's like it's just a block
or two away from her house they're
called Mariah I'm like hey honey do you
want go to Roscoe's chick and she's like
yes try that so like we we go down there
and we get chicken and waffles well we
get one order chicken waffles to share
and then I got like like side a potato
salad and greens or something I mean all
in all it wasn't like the most horrible
meal in the world but my my point is is
because I don't eat that stuff on a
regular basis because Mariah doesn't
need that stuff on a regular basis when
we had it it was just like because it's
like we're not we're not you and now if
we were constantly eating you know fried
chicken and waffles and syrup and like
which believe me it's tempting to go
back to that kind of but but if we were
doing that I'm sure like this would have
been one of the best chicken and waffles
we've ever had but since we have kind of
cut those things out of our life like
now even when we do have it it's not as
exactly about you any grocery shopping
tips I'm really bad with groceries
because I feel like I don't buy anything
else so food is where I kind of like let
it loose a little bit but I also don't
buy anything in plastic packaging so
that restricts me a lot with I could buy
Oreos anyway yeah right so it helps you
to like not buy like processed foods
yeah yeah yeah I so my short answer is
just a silly one it's from Glengarry
Glen Ross put that coffee down coffee's
for closers so don't don't tweet that
Sean that's not my quote
what I really do what I really I mean
put that food down that you're
considering buying if you know it's not
good for you and the one thing I do to
stave off impulse the rule that I have
in place is when I go to the grocery
store it happened Beck's and I have a
shared list on on our phones and so we
updated together but if it's not on that
list when I'm at the store no matter if
I intended to put it on the list
blueberries oh they're not on the list I
think I'm not going to buy I forced
myself to go home put it back on the
list if I really wanted that bad
yes I'm creating an inconvenience for
myself but really what I'm doing I was
creating enough friction to force myself
to not buy those things I don't really
need and most of the time when you don't
buy something that you thought you
needed you end up not missing out on it
anyway you realize you didn't really
care and it didn't make a difference
that you don't have it yeah well my pity
answer is this if you take away a bad
habit and don't replace it with
something good it won't be long before a
bad habit is back in your life so you
know al the way you could stop buying so
much food is yes create that friction
create some boundaries but we find a way
to still go out and get something that's
enjoyable like the Oreos versus the
hundred percent is it Montezuma is that
what it's called over at Trader Joe's I
think it's what it is yeah but yeah dark
chocolate yeah which is really difficult
like it's not a treat at first at first
you're like oh my god like this is
flavorless chocolate no it does not like
it because she's had child's chocolate
right yeah but if you if you stick with
it though your body does start to adapt
your taste buds adapt but yeah al you do
still have to replace what you want to
stop buying you've got to replace it
with with something good or yeah the bad
habit will be right back in your life
all right looks like we have several
more surprise questions this week these
are some interesting ones I maintain
good credit without buying things with
credit cards how do i establish
financial freedom when I still must pay
for essential services how do i purchase
fewer clothes fewer books less perfume
fewer candles and less makeup this is
why we brought you in show business I
talked to my wife about this too so I
don't really have an opinion other than
like my adjacent opinion to that we'll
talk about that in a moment
also I won't talk about other things
that Ryan and I and also Shelby have
gotten rid of what do we stop the buying
and why did we stop buying those things
we'll dive deep on that also things this
is a fascinating one things we started
buying after becoming minimalist is
there anything that we started buying
after becoming a minimal so I got the
list of a few things that might surprise
you also things we wish we could stop
buying this is real confession time Ryan
what do you wish you could stop by we're
gonna talk about that also six questions
to ask yourself before buying something
new and twelve ways to stop wasting
money and take control of your stuff and
if want to hear all that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listen to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't always discuss in public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it a hundred
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our minimal or I'm
sorry that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
get access to our entire back catalogue
of more than a hundred private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including additional
private podcast episode every week over
at the minimalists com a slash support
Ryan what else you got for us this week
you know being informed is more
important than ever especially today we
just like live in a Meem culture and
it's very easy to like read a meme and
be like nuff said don't need to look at
anything else but man we really got to
dig into stuff so as always I just want
to encourage people to read more and get
informed and now here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners I
feel a minimalist I just wanted to leave
this tip because it has been a recent
shift in my way of thinking on the
podcast when I used to hear people or
even Josh and Ryan discussing like
consuming consciously and thinking about
the companies where they purchase things
I felt like that was too much work to do
the research behind companies and
recently I've kind of realized that my
power and
a comes from the things that I'm
spending my money on in our current
society and so it actually seems like a
very small price to pay to do the
research and purchase products from
places that care about the environment
and that treat their employees well
because I suppose the alternative is
spending money on goods in places that
maybe don't care about their employees
and don't treat the environment well and
then if I am purchasing from them then
in a way I am supporting those behaviors
which don't align with my values
hi Josh and Ryan this is Gina calling
from Hershey Pennsylvania I have a
listener tip for finding free reading
material for avid readers on a budget
there's the local library in which were
usually the most familiar with but there
might be other larger libraries
available to you within your state for
example as a Pennsylvania resident you
can access the materials at the
Philadelphia free library absolutely for
free which is a much larger collection
than my local library I use an app
called overdrive and log in with my
local and state library information I
have two different collections to search
from without ever stepping foot into
this library I've downloaded countless
audio and ebooks it works just like a
regular library if something isn't
available you can place a hold and
you'll be notified when it's ready I'd
recommend doing some research for your
state to see if there are other
libraries you might not have known that
you have access to all right y'all
thanks again to Shelby for joining us
today thank you for being here today
we're really grateful thank you
I want to encourage folks to check out
your YouTube channel we'll put a link to
it in the show notes check out her
videos about eco-friendly and living and
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist we have a side
project it's called minimalism dot life
we partnered up with the folks from well
Carl from minimalism oh and Alberto from
five style to bring you the best and
minimalist well-being well there's so
much with minimalism it's like we we are
good at essays and talking about
minimalism the well-being side of things
right right but uh you know I'm not I
don't have the best style that's really
why I have only one outfit is because
like I really don't know how to dress
myself but uh but yeah I mean we've got
a Karl with basically does with
minimalist design and then we've got a
traveling you know some traveling
aspects of minimum lease of minimalism
about life to alberto from minimum lease
email right from five style from five
Celje all right if you all want to check
that out it's minimalism dot life you
can also follow minimalism life on
social media it's at minimalism on
twitter and at minimalism life on
Instagram some beautiful photos over
there you can check it out there's a
weekly journal there's free wallpapers
that will declutter your phone quite a
bit make it beautiful and also we've
done a recent wet web site revamp over
there so it looks beautiful minimalism
that life if you have a question comment
or minim
tip for our podcast leave us a voicemail
for zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimus if you want our show
notes and your inbox sign up for our
email list at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week but never spam because
that stuff's gross for I added value
this week this just happened rest of
peace to Nipsey Hussle you hear about
this yeah la rapper 33 years old and was
he was gunned down in front of his his
clothing store and was sad about this he
was really a pillar of a community like
the ideal story of someone growing up in
poverty and not just leaving poverty
behind but empowering his neighborhood
he he owned several businesses in South
Central
including the clothing store that he was
killed and in front of and it's it can
happen to anyone and it's really
unfortunate but we're gonna leave you
today with well he is a grammy-nominated
album called victory lap it was his most
recent album that came out last year and
here is my favorite song from that album
it's called double up by Nipsey Hussle
featuring belly and Dom Kennedy if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus